- Hey guys, I'm starting a new series
called, "Analyzing the Original."
This is where I look at content
that I put out in the world,
and I try to add more context.
This could be a really fruitful series,
so we're gonna try it out.
We're trying to innovate.
You've seen over under.
We're gonna try to do this,
and let's get into the first episode.
You could've ended up being a bus, a tree.
I just don't get the mentality
of being head down, sad
on a Monday morning.
Ah, the classic.
- [Drock] So what went through your head
on February 22nd, 2015
that you thought you
had to make this video?
- Were we doing Daily V?
- [Drock] No, because of quarantine.
- Why were you there?
Did I text you in the morning and say--
- [Drock] On Saturday night
before you got hyped--
- (bell dinging) I now remember.
I was reading, I mean almost everything
that I come up with comes
from reading and listening.
I always talk about, you hear me talking,
you hear me interrupting people on sh...
The reason I interrupt,
I think, in podcasts,
is I've already heard what
the person's gonna say,
and I do a bad job really
thinking about the audience,
'cause I'm in the moment,
and I'm not a great
interviewer for that reason.
But I am listening, and I
was reading comments, Drock
and was like, "Damn, people
fucking hate Monday."
And I was like, "We need to
change the perspective on this."
People are really depressed,
anxious, upset, angry
and they're alive, and they
can do something about it.
So first, let's put
things into perspective,
and I really just, right, I texted you.
I was like, "Come over Monday morning.
"We're gonna film this shit."
I'm glad that it was a gloomy day.
I'm glad it turned out to be like this.
This is a real classic.
- [Drock] What made this video
so successful do you think?
- A couple things happened.
I think it caught a lot of people's truth,
which is, in general, what
I think my content does.
I think the setting was very raw and real.
I mean this is now,
Drock, we're getting old,
this is six years ago.
This did really well on Instagram?
- [Drock] On Facebook.
- On Facebook.
It was just raw.
It was super real.
I really meant it.
I feel like I'm always at
my best when I mean it.
- [Drock] Do you remember
how you ended the video?
- No.
- [Drock] Do you remember
how you started the video?
- I can almost feel the start,
but I don't necessarily remember.
- [Drock] Cool, let's
watch, ah wait, wait.
Actually, I was gonna have
you try to recreate it
before you listen to it.
- You could have been
hit by a fucking bus!
I remember the bus coming by.
You could have been born a tree,
or you could be born a bus.
You could have ended
up being a bus, a tree.
- [Drock] All right, ready?
- So it's early Monday morning,
and I've been wanting to
make a Monday morning video
for a long time, and finally,
Drock, we're doing it.
So, real quick--
Stop right there.
A couple weeks ago, I wrote a blog post
about smoke then fire.
(bell dinging)
I'm always smoking, I'm always smoking.
So clearly, what happened in that weekend
was I read enough Dms or emails
that finally got me over the
top, that my smoke became fire,
which was me saying that to the audience
is like, this has been
on my mind, and it has.
People hating Monday is
something I've really been
in tune with, because I hated Monday
from 1982 to 1998, 'cause I hated school.
- [Drock] Okay, go ahead.
- This is just a rant, very simple
and something that I want you to pass on
or watch every Monday morning,
because the level of
complaining is unacceptable.
Look, what if I told you
this was the last Monday
morning of your life?
Right.
What if I told you you died this week?
Would you complain about your crap job?
Think about that.
Today, I was with a guy for 15 minutes
who's working with the Sasha Group,
and he talked about always
hearing me about this,
always resonated, and then
his son had a brain tumor.
And he was going so hard,
all these businesses,
and he was like, "Who gives a shit!"
I was like, "Yeah."
And, people need to know that.
People are complaining right now
about pay, about burnout,
about COVID, not going skiing
and cool, I get it, and
there's nothing wrong
with being disappointed.
But fucking dwelling and
devastated and life is ruined
when there's so much pain in the world
around people who have
really lost loved ones
or died or really, really
affected by this disease,
you gotta put things in perspective.
And I really do believe that people
would not hate their Monday
and complain about their job
if they knew that it
was their last Monday.
They just wouldn't think
about the world that way.
And I think living that
way while being patient,
it's that friction of
the opposite opinion.
Live like it's your last day on Earth
but anticipate living for 50 years.
It's a tough juxtaposition
for people to handle opposite thinking.
And I think that's what
really works for me.
Or that test you don't
want to take, I doubt it.
You go much higher level thinking.
Well, that's really what it takes.
It takes understanding that if
you're not pumped right now,
if you're begrudging
what you're about to do,
(whispering) begrudging...
If you're not looking forward to it.
Look, I respect practicality.
You gotta go through school,
because your parents want--
Don't begrudge, kids!
You've gotta pay your rent.
You've got student loans, I get it.
But please recognize--
By the way, that's just a moment,
if we're doing the analyst,
like, who gives a fuck
that I didn't say a word.
You got the point.
People stop, because they're like,
"Oh, I lisped a little bit on that word."
I don't give a fuck.
Just penetrate through.
People will connect
with your authenticity,
not if you pronounced a word properly.
Anybody that gets caught
up on fucking pronunciation
and grammar is playing the
fucking small game anyway.
- [Drock] Why do people get caught up?
- Because they're fucking
Mike Rowe, fear-based,
they need to control little things
to make them feel comfortable,
because they're nitpicking,
because they're trying
to tear down the person
that's making the content,
because they wish they were.
Because they grew up in proper framework
where it was unacceptable,
but there's so much
deep unhappiness playing
in that framework.
There's nobody ecstatic and glowing
that they live the life properly
around pronunciation
or grammar, I promise.
This internet thing created
way more opportunity
for all of us, way more!
I mean look--
When you know the world's
abundant, you can get happy.
You're mom and dad could've had
sex like three minutes later
and you wouldn't even exist...
That's true.
and you're complaining.
You couldn't ended up being a bus...
Who wants to be a bus?
A tree, I just don't get the mentality
of being head down, sad
on a Monday morning.
It's not practical.
I'm gonna make Monday morning my bitch!
I'm gonna make you
Saturday, Monday morning!
That's what I want to do, and
that's what I want from you.
Please, take a step back,
and think about how
awesome it actually is.
A hundred percent.
And then, recognize that
you can attack the world
in a totally different way,
'cause you were lucky enough
to be born during this era.
Life is how you see it.
Fuck you Monday.
(laughing)
Yeah, honestly, Monday,
the brand pisses me off
the way other things,
branding of things that are,
Friday, thank God it's Friday.
Humpday, it's like a
whole systematic machine
to accept being unhappy in your job.
It's not a good idea,
and I think life is how you see it.
And if you think it's
supposed to be a life
of not liking your job and
you just gotta get through it.
Put on your hat, things
that you have to do,
keeping it real, (sighing)
keeping it real negative.
A lot of people are
I want to keep it real,
real, real positive.
There's always opportunity if
you take on accountability,
patience, practicality,
focus, you can make it better,
because millions and tens
of millions and hundreds
of millions of people have
made their lives better
over the last 30 years, so why can't you?
That's real talk.
I'm really glad I said that,
'cause that's fucking truth.
If tens of millions of
people over the last 25 years
have figured out a way to
make their life better,
why can't you?
Look, I'm a feedback machine as you heard.
Please leave a comment, if
I've ever brought you value,
please leave a comment right now,
so I can get a sense
of where this is going.
What do you like about this?
What stood out?
What should we be thinking about.
This community of ours
is a togetherness thing.
I need your feedback.
Set your alerts, triple
digits on Instagram,
bells and whistles on YouTube.
Set your alerts.
I need your feedback,
'cause I want to make it better.
I want to make it better for you.
Please leave your comments
on this new series.
YouTube watcher, what's up, it's Gary Vee.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you, please subscribe,
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode,
stories, polls, more content,
more engagement, more
surprise and delight.
This, is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it,
and I hope I see you soon.